like i don't understand the obsession
with people wanting wild animals as pets
i i don't understand either even people
dude i saw a woman
in trader joe's ready for this had a had
a baby ferret
in a baby bjorn on her chest she's so
single
so just looking there was this little
ferret right and i walk up to her it was
in the in the produce section
and i go hey is that a ferret she goes
yeah
cute right i go no no i'm sorry not fair
possum
baby possible oh i go is that a possum
and she goes shoot she goes yeah and i
go
do you have a possum in trader joe's she
goes yeah but it's cleaner than
everybody in here i go no
no no oh is it yeah and she goes she
goes no no
no it is i clean it every day and she
goes plus i go you can't have a
possum in trader joe's and she goes well
nobody's told me to leave i go
wait right here yeah and i watch you
snitch on it oh yo i walked
i walk over the manager i go hey are you
i just out of curiosity is is
are you allowed to bring a possum in
here and he goes what i go
[ __ ] can you break a possibility i go
possum he goes no there's no possums
allowed i go there there's one in here
yeah yeah dude i mean listen i'm not a
snitch but
i would like to buy produce here dude
that thing those things look
vicious they're ugly dude dude i
remember in college we would go
tubing down the colorado river like that
was our thing the college football
players would do it
and there's this big girl big woman
had a that thing's cute at the bottom of
the big year with the big ears she
she had a i swear to god had a straight
up
wolf as a pet and it was a
timberwolf and it's the biggest animal
i've ever seen in person
and she would just have it on its leash
and we're all like oh i guess that's
legal
no it's not dude it was so dangerous
you know that dog park up on mulholland
near laurel canyon yeah
so when i used to walk my dog up there
this dude used to bring this
giant i used to think it was a husky but
the hot that dude
the husky what i was calling it used to
just walk along the fence
and that was his whole walk but he
stayed by the perimeter on the fence
and i asked i go your dog that husky and
he goes yeah he's
at least half wolf and i was like what
he goes yeah
and i guess what he was explaining to me
he goes part of that of being the wolf
is it walks its perimeter
so it used to just walk the fence but
and other dogs you know dogs are curious
they didn't
they would run up to sniff and they'd
get within like ten feet like oh and
they'd stop and be like
oh not one of us nothing smells like
yeah dude look at
you i'm telling you that's what that
girl had in boulder colorado and we were
all so stupid like
oh that's cool like she's like yeah he's
not he's not really friendly don't pet
him
you know what there is yeah no [ __ ] it
because it'll eat your arm
yeah we are like the same thing dude
that's the biggest husky we've ever seen
the that looks like something from harry
potter why the [ __ ]
it does doesn't it something from
twilight
twilight the [ __ ] you know we had these
possum dude
beth and i at this house we lived at in
studio city right so beth and i were
sleeping one night
and outside of our window we heard and
we could hear something
up against the wall up against the wall
i know what the [ __ ] is that i looked
and there was just there was two possums
having sex and this possum was
jamming this other possum's head into
that progressive and so
but i was like i thought it was funny i
go there's two possums [ __ ] and she
goes it is so gross get him out of here
so i start going hey
hey let me tell you something about this
male possum he just looked up
gave me a and just kept [ __ ] looking
at it looking at me
don't give up i turn to beth i go well
he's now he's eye contact
like he's [ __ ] her and he's got i got
to leave him yeah
but she said spray water did they give a
[ __ ] with the water
no it's a possum they're so gangster
this possum was like i'm getting it yeah
whatever we need water
keep doing it we're hot anyways i did
need a little yeah
awesome yeah hey man you lost a bunch
that's why i
saw him yesterday like 25 you know what
i mean i'm trying to you know
uh it's just it's just you know what you
realize
the reason why you gain so much weight
in regular society is because you eat
out a lot if you're a person that eats
out a lot yeah so i was i mean
i was like you know eating out taking my
girl we just eating out all the time and
that's just buttery bread all this kind
of stuff good stuff so then the clove it
hit and that was like i was ordering
food services where i was cooking the
food myself
next thing you know i was like what you
know yeah portion control and stuff
that's the big one is portion control
because i used to get these little meals
and then i was like freshly i started
with freshly but then their delivery
people are pieces of [ __ ] you tried
hellofresh
no i haven't tried that yeah we did that
no but here's the problem man i live in
like a uh
townhouse of things so like you have to
get buzzed in that kind of stuff
and those
you know what i mean so i called him i
said yo um i'm out i'm out i told
freshly i'm out
all right because they they save money
because they get
these delivery services which is just
like regular people and regular people
don't give a [ __ ]
they don't even want that job they're
only doing it to make ends meet this
ain't their dream to like deliver
freshly you know so they already they
already think they better than the job
deliver it freshly no they don't want
five-star reviews yeah they don't care
they already think they better than this
job yeah they're like i'm not going in
i'm leaving this right here you know
what i mean
so i had to stop but anyways those meals
and then when kobe hit now we got to
treat these people like they're heroes
you know what i mean yeah
this [ __ ] is leaving the [ __ ]
it's true like they're working on the
front yeah
they're leaving the [ __ ] in the middle
of the street and i got to be like this
thank you for your service
thank you for your service enough oh
anyways so you would get these little
meals
you know when i would eat these little
meals and i'd be like i'm actually full
so what i was realizing is like i just
was overeating and eating too much and
then it's hard to maintain but anyways
since this i i've lost weight because
i've changed my habits so
but anyways the only people i know in
quarantine to lose weight
usually put on the quarantine 20. no i
don't i don't know if that's true really
yeah like my friends get big yeah
because all your friends got like
big fridge money they got three fridges
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one fridge for
me all his friends his fridge is like
yes
you know i don't know about all of them
so they don't have friends in their
freezers
you know some don't have fridges anymore
right here
nonsense but just [ __ ] yeah yeah
i've stumbled on a show
last night it's i forget the name right
look this [ __ ] up chin it's about
kids who have uh they're on the spectrum
it's a dating show oh it's on the
spectrum have you cried
is it called on this yeah if you're not
crying at that show
you're a serious you're a monster you're
serious crazy yeah it's like you know
you know what it shows what the show
it shows that love on the spectrum we
all have
issues communicating we don't realize
that we should all take
a certain level of thoughtfulness
in how we communicate and because they
have an excuse
so their excuse is like they have autism
that's right but they're so honest
and they're so honest it's the best
right but how about the dude
that dudes on his first date have you
seen it
they're just so out of throw their first
date and she's a white girl you know and
he go
and she goes well how do you think it's
going it goes oh it's lovely but you
know i'm into uh mexicans and
asians and she's all well i'm white he
goes i know i think we're better off
friends
i'm like god damn brother don't hurt him
man but
you know it's part of you like man i
wish i could be that honest all the time
oh my god aspergy honest like that is
but the way that
but but i'm saying it's like it's so
moving i agree like
you're so touching the way they try
because they were trying to work through
this
like debilitating by the way they do it
so
well yeah because you could well done
yeah you could really [ __ ] that up and
go back out because there's one guy on
there he's my [ __ ] he's such a
i walked into my girl watching it and
she's just see the guy in the green
right there
so homeboy on the right there my
favorite part is he's never been on a
date there's some
his first day is a suit on and uh his
mom goes how do you think he's gonna go
he goes
well i think what i wanted to go is you
know they're going to say at my
funeral that this guy loved this girl
more than anything in the world
and the dad's like pump the brakes dog
funeral let's just go on the date first
yeah we had two kids yeah that's what
one kid wanted to go to ohio state but
he couldn't
because he stayed at minnesota and he
wanted to be a legacy
you hear the dad go you hear the dad go
god damn like dude
pump the brakes just go on the date and
take her from there it's tough it's
tough how about the one girl brings the
the video game
because she was so into video games in
the the her way of like seeing if the
dude was cool
is they're like talking to you guys do
you like video games he's like i guess
she busts out nintendo and they're
they're playing he wasn't very good
and then he goes the bathroom and she's
like i'm not really into he's not very
good at video games
and he hears it
it is what it is